et voilà ma recette est terminée elle
est inscrite il ne me reste plus qu'à
l'exécuter oui aujourd'hui je vais faire
un plat très simple d eux avec elie à
différentes façons de faire ce plat je
vais vous donner la mienne
tout d'abord pourquoi eux à la tripe
parce que trip qui désigne en général
les intestins des animaux vient d'un mot
saxons un vieux mot saxo et qui veut
dire lanières et voilà pourquoi on
découpe les en lanières c'est à dire en
fines rondelles
ainsi que les oignons vous prenez dont 2
oignons à peu près de cette taille que
vous découpez comme je le disais en
fines lanières pour ne pas avoir
d'ennuis et ne pas pleurer
en épluchant les oignons trempé
simplement votre couteau dans de longs
et d'oublier épluchez votre et si vous
sentez le moindre picotements aux yeux
retremper immédiatement le couteau dans
l'eau le non être un très très très
vieux les deux originaires d'asie et
même dernièrement on a retrouvé l'oignon
l état sppe ont-elles votre foi
chez les égyptiens l'oignon était à
l'honneur et était même considéré comme
une divinité une délit et chose curieuse
il y a quelques années dans le
sarcophage d'une momie on a trouvé entre
ses mains crispées un oignon desséché
l'idée vain de mettre cette union dans
l'eau l'oignon se mit à germer on le mit
après dans la terre et après plus de
deux mille ans cet oignon ressuscite
verdi fleury et produisit son fruit wes
les oignons découpés en fines lamelles
ne s'agit plus maintenant que des les
faire sauter dans le buzz
faisons donc sauter les oignons dans 80
g de beurre
ce plat est temps naturellement conçu
pour deux personnes le beurre fondu
plaçons les oignons
[Musique]
et laissons les légèrement aussi mais
n'oublions pas d'assaisonner poivron est
selon
selon les oignons pour qu'il soit bien
russie de chaque côté
en attendant qu'ils soient russes y
faisons chauffer un quart de litre de
lait
retournons les oignons et dès qu'ils
seront pris une teinte blonde légèrement
doré saupoudrons l'est avec une bonne
cuillerée à soupe de farine
d'accord
surveillons le lait il ne s'échappe pas
car je n'ai pas envie d'anti montrait
pourtant choses pratiques
le lait qu est un aliment considéré
comme complet car il contient tous les
principes actifs est nécessaire à la
mitterie sion pour l'organisme d'un
individu il ya beaucoup de lait en
cuisine mais autrefois les hébreux et
les roms préférait à tous les laits le
lait de chèvre les arabes aussi ils sont
le grand pasteur aime beaucoup le nay et
des la plus haute antiquité
chose curieuse il préférait le lait de
chamelle
car paraît-il le lait de chamelle
tournée et fermenter produit produit un
liquide ou un livre en une boisson
enivrante ce qui nous montre bien que
depuis les temps les plus reculés
les hommes ont toujours cherché à son
livre dès que les oignons sont
légèrement roussi cette fois ci nous
pouvons placer alors le lait chaud
lorient
et les gens cuir maintenant sept et huit
minutes de façon
que le lait réduisent un peu et
s'amalgament avec la farine on arrivera
à obtenir ainsi une pure et une purée
d'oignons presque
laissons mourir et en attendant le temps
nécessaire le moment est venu de
préparer les eaux occupons nous des d3e
que l'on a fait durci faut d'abord les
éplucher naturellement
voici en lamelles
apparu
[Musique]
deuxièmement je roule les oeufs dans mes
mains pour avoir plus de facilités pour
les éplucher après vous voyez la
coquille s'en va parfaitement bien et
maintenant également en lamelles willam
elle égale tripes
la meilleure preuve c'est que
l'intérieur d'un cigare les feuilles de
tabac en lamelles s'appelle des tricks
ont dit les tripes d'un cigare voici est
maintenant troisième of même opération
sinon se laver les mains décorticage
et encore
belhamel en ayant soin d'en garder 4
deux côtés quatre belles pour toutes à
leur décor et le plein
voici les quatre ils serviront à décorer
le plat et les autres places on l'est
dans les oignons et lol
là et maintenant laissons cuir les gens
adorent un petit bout de temps tout en
tournant toujours la sauce naturel en
cuisine on peut dire qu'il y a quatre
catégorique de la première catégorie
ce sont les moelleux la deuxième
catégorie
mais ce free la troisième les oeufs durs
et la 4e les oeufs employé comme agent
libre choses assez curieuse surtout dans
les mois le sait que les deux mois le
comprennent tout d'abord les oeufs crus
vous savez que les rues sont excellents
pour la gorge pour la voix mais pour que
réellement il fasse de l'effet et qu'il
ne soit pas indigeste
il faut les gober avant la poule est
sûre fini de chanter c'est assez
difficile quand on se trouve loin d'un
poulailler naturellement mais enfin
c'est comme ça les deux mois le comprend
aussi les mollets mais ce free ce sont
les oeufs sur le plat
les oeufs à l'huile les oeufs durs vous
venez de lait noir tant qu eux employés
comme agents dans la cuisine
ce sont les yeux les jaunes servant de
liaison pour les sauces et les blancs
servant à faire des pâtisseries ou des
soufflets une grave question se pose
depuis très longtemps
les savants se sont toujours demandés si
la poule a été fait avant l'oeuf ou
l'oeuf avant la et ceci a permis un
charmant poète de faire une petite
poésie
jouer c'est revoir le plaisir de vous
conter fidon l'oeuf avant la poule
fitton la poule avant l'oeuf dans ce
cercle étroit
je roule ne découvrant rien de neuf de
résoudre ce problème
bien que j'en sois désireux je préfère
au bien mieux j'aime les déguster tout
l'aide
en effet il ya des quantités de façon de
déguster les quarante les accommoder
d'une façon une nombre tant qu'à la
poule
n'en parlons pas même notre bon roi
henri henri le quatrième volet que
chaque paysan et le dimanche sa poule au
pot il est vrai que à cette époque
certain esprit révolutionnaire
prétendait que malgré la poule
ce n'était pas la poule qui était plus
mais maintenant les oeufs sont
suffisamment réchauffé on peut les
servir
réparons d'eau les quatre of les câpres
rondelle plutôt en réservant la
cinquième pour mettre au milieu et verso
au milieu des quatre de façon à ce que
le cinquième viennent sur le dessus
comme un petit chapiteau voici et
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à déguster
voici donc les oeufs à la grippe et
j'espère que lorsque vous aurez
confectionner ses oeufs vous ne penserez
pas qu'ils ne valent que trimestre
suivant une vieille expression est
maintenant si vous le voulez bien je
vais vous dicter la recette complète de
saison prenez un crayon et une feuille
de papier à la tripe pour deux
coupez en fines lamelles de bois oignons
faites les revenir dans une casserole
avec 80 g de beurre
assaisonner lorsque les oignons commence
à bleau dire
saupoudrez avec une cuillérée à soupe de
farine tournée lui
cinq minutes environ après verser un
quart de lait préalablement chauffé
laisser cuire à feu moyen en tournant de
temps en temps pendant sept à huit
minutes placé alors 3e dur que vous
aurez couper en rondelles
laissez cuire encore quelques minutes et
servez bien chaud puis déguster
[Musique]